qué mirada a terraza no siendo usted una
experta en lenguas indígenas desde el
punto de vista de una persona que hable
de esas lenguas en forma nativa si se ha
dedicado a la enseñanza de las mismas
aquí en canadá cómo es esto de qué se
trata cuéntenos por favor
bien
en mi experiencia es con el instituto y
una
donde desde el año 2018 existe un
programa de arlette comunicación artes
letras y comunicación y en este programa
hay
hay dos opciones para los alumnos
pueden elegir aprender la lengua porque
no la hablan o pueden especializarse en
el conocimiento de su propia lengua que
su lengua materna su lengua primera no
del mismo modo que nosotros
escolarizados en español tenemos cursos
de clases de castells de lengua
castellana bueno serían cursos de lengua
materna no
yo tuve experiencia enseñando los dos
las dos opciones
lo importante es que nunca estuve sola
en la clase nosotros la propuesta de que
una fuera hacer un trabajo de equipo con
claudio está agua que es la errática en
la lengua que son señas de la tica mec
mi colega estéticamente que ella tiene
una licenciatura en lingüística solo que
ella no había estudiado su lengua
materna como objeto de estudio ella se
había especializado más en la
lingüística francesa entonces le faltaba
tanto el conocimiento de la lengua en sí
y de la parte más gramatical la
estructura cómo funciona y la
experiencia de enseñanza de docencia lo
que yo hice fue acompañar a claudio en
la clase aportándole los métodos de
didáctica de la enseñanza de lenguas que
los he ido adquiriendo a lo largo de mi
experiencia enseñanza del español como
lengua segunda y la compañía también en
la parte más estructural entonces como
yo en mi estudio de lingüística me
especialicé en entender cómo funcionan
estas lenguas bueno tengo como el
mecanismo de la lengua lo conozco muy
bien pero nunca lo he puesto en práctica
nunca he tomado digamos he tenido la
suerte de poder aprender el vocabulario
de poder practicar la lengua y entonces
él
y mi rol en todo esto es aportar el
conocimiento técnico de la lengua junto
con la experiencia de la metodología de
enseñanza de una lengua segunda noveno
por favor también de que uno del
instituto en el cual usted se desempeña
desde el centro educativo en el cual se
desempeña es uno de los pocos sino el
único
digamos motorizado por los propios
nativos con los puertos indígenas
si en realidad en la provincia de québec
es el único es la única institución
que es creada por y para las primeras
naciones y los pueblos indígenas de
canadá
es una institución que de alguna forma
es la continuidad de un colegio como en
la idea del sep en quebec que existió a
los años 70 que el colegio magnitud y
que fue es agarrado luego de tres años
de funcionamiento y este esta nueva
institución existe del 2011 y está
afiliada al consejo de educación de las
primeras naciones les esperan que a su
vez está afiliado a la asamblea de los
primeros pueblos las hombres de spanair
nación
que beckett el abogado de la provincia
de québec entonces es realmente una
institución indígena creada por para
indígenas pero la abierta a todo el
mundo eso es lo que tiene interesante
que no es restrictiva
una persona que no es de ascendencia
indígena puede estudiar en esta
institución y cuántos estudiantes el
curso es muy pequeño el colegio son este
año creo que son 70 los alumnos que
tenemos pero son así es de todos los
años es más o menos es el promedio a
unos años más quizás 100 o 50 va
variando entre sus pequeños colegios
primer algo como lingüista usted lo sabe
mejor que yo se habla de las lenguas
como la columna vertebral de la cultura
de un pueblo más allá de las
declaraciones continuas que se hacen no
solamente en quebec en canadá en general
y en otras naciones que también cuentan
con pueblos originarios que existe aquí
una real interés en conocer las lenguas
indígenas canadienses o quebequenses en
particular
y yo diría que eso ha cambiado mucho en
los últimos años
[Música]
si estuviéramos en esta entrevista hace
15 20 años diría claramente que no pero
en los últimos años de historia en los
últimos 5 años podemos incluso decir 10
hay cada vez más interés por ejemplo si
no toman el caso de mojarlos dr
montreal indígena que es un organismo
que tiene como objetivo
y dar un espacio de encuentro un espacio
cultural un espacio de seguridad
cultural como se dice
a la gente que es de origen indígena y
que vive en la ciudad ellos ofrecen
cursos de lenguas de varias lenguas como
cinco o seis lenguas
todos los años desde que han creado los
programas hay listas de espera y no son
sólo los alumnos no son solo de ellos
pertenecientes a una primera nación sino
que es gente de la población en general
lo mismo pasa en la universidad de
montreal le están dando en este momento
desde hace dos años creó un curso de y
no esos ofrecen cuatro niveles de inuk
los cursos están siempre completos y no
son solamente
y personas pertenecientes a una primera
nación
conocer una lengua no siendo nativo de
la misma permite conocer a los pueblos
que la hablar
ese es un gran debate en lingüística hay
distintos puntos de vista
hay gente hay una corriente que
considera que hay algo que hay algo más
universal en las lenguas y que
finalmente esas diferencias son
estéticas no más no como un maquillaje y
hay otras corrientes como más
lingüística cognitiva diría yo
en la que
en la que no al contrario se considera
que uno cuando esté pensando en otra
lengua está como organizando las ideas
desde otro lado y después está toda la
cuestión de común no nombre a la
realidad que eso es indiscutible
claramente nombramos la realidad según
nuestra experiencia y evidentemente en
la lengua encontramos un montón de
manifestaciones que provienen de que
provienen de la cultura entonces mi
opinión personal es que sí que uno a
través de la lengua puente under
descubrir sobre todo percepciones y como
uno
como uno categoriza el mundo también le
digo un ejemplo rapidísimo pero la gente
con la que eso trabaje en argentina de
los wichis
la palabra miel no existe como miel
porque hay como seis o siete variedades
entonces cada vez que uno dice miel
tiene que saber de qué abeja o de qué
avispa viene y entonces eso para mí es
interesante quizás no a nivel cognitivo
porque bueno cualquier persona lo podría
aprender pero nos está informando sobre
qué relaciones sostienen con esa
naturaleza que no es la misma que ponen
el sol de habiendo crecido en una ciudad
sin ese tipo de conocimientos en el caso
de las lenguas indígenas canadienses que
usted ha abordado existen términos
palabras que no existan en español en
francés o en inglés sigue un montón
un montón generalmente a mí me fascina
este tema porque además tengo una
formación de traductora mi información
original de traductor entonces
generalmente siempre para mí esto es
algo que me intriga saber como diríamos
como se diría y bueno muchas veces
estamos en situaciones en las que bueno
no se dice pero
en los dos sentidos del mismo modo en
que por ahí hay gente que dice no pero
la palabra gracias en algonquin o por
ejemplo no no existe y ahora la estamos
usando porque es algo que se fue
desarrollando con el contacto bueno del
mismo modo
no sé no tenemos un verbo para decir ir
a buscar agua y traerla en el hombro por
ejemplo es bueno esos van a tener un
verbo así y van a tener otro que es
caminar en la nieve tirando un peso en
la espalda
y bueno no hay una palabra para decirlo
nosotros lo que vamos a hacer es buscar
una paráfrasis y lo vamos a traducir con
el equivalente de nuestras lenguas pero
no tenemos una palabra lexical no
tenemos una palabra entera para decir
designar esa realidad eso se emparenta
con aquella vieja idea del autor en su
laberinto del que hablaban algunos
estudiosos no es cierto exactamente
exactamente discriminada usted me lo
mostraba antes de comenzar la entrevista
ha escrito un libro sobre gramática de
lenguas indígenas ha de ser es una
experiencia sumamente enriquecedora pero
además un desafío enorme para alguien
que no es lo decíamos antes de hablar y
lo dijimos ya varias veces en entrevista
a alguien que no es nativo de esas
lenguas como encara usted de semejante
trabajo la verdad que le agradezco le
pregunté porque es algo que para mí fue
enriquecedor en varios sentidos la
historia de este libro es que fue un
pedido de el consejo acá pero no está en
la noción de consejos de banda no que es
como la la entidad política de cada
comunidad
el muscle first nation council que son
los crisis del lado oeste de canadá que
viven cerca de la bahía
james me encargó hacer una introducción
a la gramática
que era como un poco para completar un
diccionario que esos habían publicado
anteriormente cuando esos publican el
diccionario la comunidad en general
empieza a decir bueno pero ahora qué
hacemos con las palabras queremos saber
un poco más de cómo se organizan cómo
hacemos atrás si queremos escribir
canciones queremos usar la lengua
entonces me pidieron hacer una gramática
de la lengua
para mí eso no era una disculpa porque
como le digo yo tengo el conocimiento
teórico de la lengua y
como buena lingüista me puse a hacer lo
que sabía hacer que era describir el
funcionamiento de la lengua el problema
es que como buena lingüista yo tengo una
visión que es como una parte técnica
no todo el mundo bueno no todo el mundo
nadie aparte de la los lingüistas
conciben la lengua como simplemente una
organización estructural donde tenemos
los verbos los nombre los sustantivos el
género etcétera
cuando uno encara una lengua la encara
como un medio de comunicación y no está
pensando en todas esas estructuras y lo
que pasó fue que cuando eso termine la
primera versión de este trabajo la gente
que me lo había encargado me dijo es muy
técnico quizás puede servir para gente
que ya es especialista para los maestros
pero un hablante que quiere saber más
sobre su lengua no no se va a encontrar
en este en esta forma de presentar la
materia
entonces me pidieron que le volviera a
escribir
y ahí fue donde vino el gran desafío
porque yo lo único que sabía hacer era
escribir una lengua desde cómo había
aprendido a hacerlo en mis estudios
gracias por suerte tuve la suerte de
tener muchos contactos en mi mundo
a través de mi vida y mi experiencia
también profesional y me acordé de mi
colega mónica ashida de aritz que es una
pionera de la educación bilingüe en
argentina mónica desde siempre me decía
usted es lingüista mira el trabajo que
me hizo tal lingüista y espero que
tienes que problema y si está perfecto
para mí está perfecto como estaba
organizado dice vistes y te das cuenta
que ustedes viven tienen como otra
consciente otra percepción de la lengua
entonces eso me acuerdo haber tenido
esta charla con ese decir bueno pero
entonces como arias para presentar la
gramática de una lengua sin hablar de la
gramática directamente y mi hijo bueno
con historias con cuentos y bueno
gracias a ese consejo de mónica eso fue
así como lo aborde entonces lo que
propongo en el libro es
esto presenta una historia se hace una
historia de antiguas hace un mito una
leyenda o algo que alguien de la
comunidad me contó porque tengo muchas
entrevistas y muchos relatos presento un
relato x y a partir del relato y
mostrando la gramática entonces eso
permite también entender el contexto de
utilización
tener ejemplos sin empezar al revés
bueno este es el sujeto esto es el verbo
no lo vemos en usándolo y después lo
entendemos lo entonces como que reverte
un poco la forma de acceder a esas
nociones
usted nombró a la argentina obviamente
no es alguien nacida aquí como llegó a
canadá porque en todo caso llegó a
canadá y de que le sirvió su experiencia
previa en argentina para llevar a cabo
su trabajo aquí
en argentina bueno porque llegué a
canadá fue por un intercambio que
existía entre la universidad de córdoba
y la universidad laval en quebec
yo estudié traductorado de francés en la
universidad de córdoba y generalmente
cuando uno termina una carrera en la que
estoy en un idioma extranjero va a vivir
o pasa un tiempo en un lugar donde se
hable ese idioma y en ese momento se le
he venir a canadá
a través de este intercambio bueno
después conocí a mi esposo que es quien
sí evidentemente así se decidió mi
destino final en canadá pero digamos que
el detonante fue este intercambio
[Música]
y bueno desde esto fue en 1997 que yo
llegué aquí pero durante muchos años
estuve viviendo seis meses aquí seis
meses en argentina porque es justamente
trabajaba con comunidades indígenas
wichi allá en argentina que ese fue mi
trabajo de doctorado y sois una maestría
y un doctorado y ese doctorado fue una
gramática de la lengua wichi sé que
desde esa época yo trabajaba sobre la
gramática
a través de esta conversación uno se da
cuenta que obtiene interesa no le ocupan
necesariamente emprendimientos fáciles
sino que sentarse en cuestiones
complicadas algún proyecto en carpeta en
ese sentido
[Risas]
y muchos muchos y le diré que en este
momento lo que más me
no me preocupe pero lo que más me
interesa es cómo mejorar todo lo que son
todo lo que es didáctica de una lengua
segunda una lengua indígena no porque es
esa una realidad que estamos viviendo
desde hace varias décadas que muchas
comunidades están perdiendo la la lengua
originaria la lengua que se habla
originalmente que está siendo
reemplazada por hacer el francés o el
inglés pero lo que también observamos es
que hay un interés que va creciendo con
el tiempo de esa gente de re aprender la
lengua lo que pasa que cuando uno quiere
aprender la lengua teniendo ya una
lengua que se ha convertido en su lengua
primera es más difícil como usted
mencionó al principio hablábamos de
aprender el francés como lengua segunda
etcétera bueno cuando uno tenga la edad
adulta o una edad avanzada no sea
adolescente incluso sea tiene una
estructura ya tiene su lengua materna
desde hace dos años entonces tiene que
aprender una lengua como lengua segundo
ya ahí es donde estamos con
con una falta de métodos claramente se
pueden adaptar los métodos de las otras
lenguas como el español como el francés
pero hay que adaptarlas a muchas otras
cuestiones número uno que no existe el
material entonces hay que fabricar
material constantemente número dos que
las lenguas si uno quiere usar un método
comunicativo que sea realmente útil para
comunicarse bueno no podemos usar los
métodos que hablan de como reservó un
hotel o como viajo voy al aeropuerto
porque todo ese vocabulario no lo
necesitamos y no existen estas lenguas
hay que hacer como toda una adaptación y
además como lo dijimos del principio de
la estructura de las lenguas es muy
diferente entonces no podemos hacer como
bueno enseñamos con muchos enseño en
español no lo puedo enseñar en la misma
forma porque no va a funcionar
simplemente entonces lo que más me
interese en este punto es todo lo que
tiene que ver con la enseñanza estas
lenguas como lenguas segundas y mis
proyectos son todos en torno a eso a ese
tema cuando esperábamos entonces en el
futuro tener noticias suyas con respecto
tiene que rozar muchas gracias porque
entrevista con rollo que nos da
internacional muchas gracias a ustedes
por invitarme